brad is with me in Phoenix Arizona hey
Brad welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up I just wanted a quick question
about the I'm worried about my stubble
with a whole ratio currently Mike and I
apparently have about a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars in student loans
and we are Arnett Arabs our take home or
I'm sorry we make about ninety thousand
dollars a year right now however next
year my VA disability because I'm a
promise table site will be decreasing
substantially to where we'll only have
about seventy thousand dollars a year
and I don't know
so what are your wording reason so my
degree is the information technology and
web development and that I'm currently
doing as a product manager my wife is
has her master's degree in psychology
but she currently is a stay-at-home
mother and homeschools my eight-year-old
okay did she ever get our license to do
counseling no she uh she's looked into
it but you know what for us to go back
to school I would cost even less you
know go back to school she's got a
master's degree in psychology you think
it's a license to do counseling in
Arizona with a master's degree in
psychology way she can get a job working
as a TR as a psychologist I got school
psychologist that was her master's
degree but she's very content and
staying as a stay-at-home mother with my
son doing the homeschooling process and
doesn't want to give that up so I'm just
wanting to make sure because the way I'm
looking at it now is we have you know if
we paid it all or everything this off in
six years that can be like twenty seven
hundred dollars a month and like thirty
thousand dollars
so you're the only one working you make
70 grand a night II correct how long
have you been doing there I've been in
for five years I recently took a new job
that gave me a pay bump to 70 was the
Nate
your disability from the military pretty
much you know quite a few things happen
to me when I was over it over in Iraq
anxiety stress PTSD and final damage
don't you how's the back hurting but I
will survive yeah and how's the other
stuff are your emotions healing I am
working with the VA to trying to better
that it's getting there it's just
there's just a lot on my plate always so
it's always a challenge I understand
getting better I understand thank you
for your service the price you pay so
how much of the hundred and sixty-five
is her master's in psychology that she's
not using so the 160,000 actually
hundred and twenty thousand of it is for
her degree and my degree I only owe
about 35 so we only really only know
about honor 55 okay I appreciate that
she is content but she made a mess to
get this degree and she needs to find
some way to create some revenue as a
result of this degree I don't know I'm
not saying she has to go to school full
I go to work full time 40 hours a week
and not see your 8 year old I'm not
suggesting that but doing some
counseling getting you're getting your
license to do one-on-one counseling and
doing some marriage counseling or doing
counseling for somebody as someone offs
at least by God part-time to do
something to offset the fact that she
went in dad $120,000 to get a degree to
be a stay-at-home mom doesn't work okay
some of those choices when she made
those choices so your family needs the
help from her
and I love her being a stay-at-home mom
she loves being a stay-at-home mom but
you guys are broke and so she's gonna
have to look at that at least for the
short term some way to create some
revenue from this